for the candid responses let's start
with money
um
very simply
just give a number ideally how much
money should your man make a year
Heather
eight figures eight figures ideally okay
so that's ten million dollars yeah
minimum I do okay ideally gotcha so I
mean ideally or realistically you ask
let's go realistically since ideally is
so you want to date
yeah you want to date an NBA player but
like the best NBA player because most
NBA players make like 3 million you want
to date the quarterback for the Miami
Dolphins no I don't think or you want to
date the CEO of Amazon all right so
athletes are out yeah athletes are out
okay so athletes are out so all your 10
million always or is this a new
um it's I've dated athletes and it's
just not my thing so I've tried it it's
just personal preference nothing against
you guys so ideally respect 10 million
[ __ ] [ __ ] by the way what percentage
of men do you think make 10 million
dollars a year I'm sure it's a very
small give it give me a number
I'm not good at the numbers I don't know
one through ten I mean you one through
ten I mean one through a hundred like
percentage it's probably like a tenth of
a percentage
0.0001 percent
all right you got this thing girl
um okay that's ideally realistically I
think six figures okay minimum yeah
gotcha all right
respect so you just went from a hundred
thousand you went from 10 million to 100
Grand okay well I'm just you said
ideally who doesn't want ideally the
most amount come on
a girl
ideally slash realistically how much
money should your man make a year
um I think ideally for me would be like
be with 70
80 70 70 80. no that's ideal no no
lose my number homie you wear like girls
on my show say this all the time like
six figures up like I have never thought
I was gonna date a guy that made six
figures why I don't you make six figures
now more than six figures yeah so don't
you want to give your kids the life that
you've had
um we we grew up pretty Frugal like we
made a lot of money but we like you had
a slide in your backyard oh yeah that's
true
I grew up on fuel assistance and Welfare
there's a very big time going to the
pool or just onto grass in the pond
that that is the sign of wealth right
there because a slide just onto the
grass you do Sports you've been able to
travel there's a lot of things that your
family like has been able to provide 70k
like it's hard to send your kids even on
an AAU team yeah okay so the question is
uh because are you getting that number
because there's a there's a a study out
there that says seventy thousand dollars
is the Baseline that creates happiness
and anything above that is more
materialism and consumerism is that
where you're getting that number I got
the number because it's a little more
than what I used to make at my sales job
okay so it's just like that's what I
used to make like roughly 50k okay so
you said ideally like honestly when I
was just thinking the same job that I
used to have
interesting I mean like what would you
say to someone who's saying Pearl you're
crushing it right now I assume you're
making way more than 70 000. what would
you say to the people out there that
it's like come on Pearl you're selling
yourself short do better
you are I mean how do I put it like
sure if that if that happened like great
I just don't think it's like that
realistic I mean it's such a small
percentage of guys that make that much
money like I think I think it would be
unrealistic of me to think oh this guy
has to make more money than me okay well
I'm gonna give you some numbers in a
second as far as like what men make and
what percentage of men make but let's go
down the line here and then I'll give
you some numbers ideally slash
realistically how much you want your man
to make ideally we're on the same page
ideally I would like yeah like a
successful entrepreneur
um who is making more money than me we
did discuss because we were on the
pre-game so tune in to her podcast
um what like my lowest would be and I
think I said 120 or 150. okay
um so minimum basis six figure man
minimum yeah okay how about you Emily
ideally I love where my ladies heads are
at let's be a little delusional you know
I'd say at least 10 million you know
what [ __ ] it let's make it 50 ml a
yearly so you guys comfortable you guys
are comfortable with being delusional
absolutely I'm not delusional I've dated
a guy whose house was eight figures okay
so I mean it's just
you know I know he's out there
you're not delusional because you've
done it before have you ever done dating
a guy who makes 10 million a year oh
please
I've dated brokies
so maybe you're delusional and she's not
yeah and you're embracing that are you
delusional honey wow okay so so
realistically yes realistically I think
on Pearl's podcast we did talk about
this minimum for if it's a single family
provider I would want my husband to be
making
120 150 around there got it okay so
there's realistically we're in the six
figures 70k category
delusional status I meet this guy making
eight figures 10 20 million bucks a year
okay now if that guy
makes 10 20 million dollars a year let's
go there for a second
uh how comfortable would you be if he
cheated on you every once in a while not
all the time
but once a year Heather I love you baby
but I'm going on a business trip by the
way I made 10 million dollars this year
so you're like you're you're like you
like your G wagon that you're driving
you like the mansion that's how it is
I agree that is how it is but there's
you know that's there's a payoff for
everything so you are comfortable with
it I'm not comfortable with it it's not
ideal if we're speaking idealistically
but once a year you'll deal with it
though
if I'm driving a G wagon I'd rather I'd
rather crying
so once a year what about 10 times a
year about once a month I mean it all
depends on the situation he's now making
20 million dollars a year
you have two g-wagons
one for you and one for your assistant
sure wow okay guys make your [ __ ]
money you'll date Miss Montana cheat on
her as much as you want but you got to
make 10 to 20 million dollars a year
yeah
and so I would be like put money in
stocks for me like start a company for
me like little things on the side where
I'm making money and you cheat on me now
flip it the dude making 70 grand a year
or even 100 Grand a year no is he
allowed to cheat on you no that guy will
treat you better so it's it's something
to treat you better the guy that makes
less money so would you rather would you
rather it's false would you rather
the guy that makes a buck 20 a year but
treats you great doesn't cheat on you
respects you or the guy that makes 10
million dollars a year probably treats
you okay but definitely cheats on you
but you're driving a G wagon which would
you pick I mean it depends on the guy I
ideally I want somebody that I can have
fun with that's really important to me
that we get along because I view
marriage as you know it's a 50 year long
conversation so if you're somebody that
I can have a good conversation with
that's what's most important to me so if
we can have fun together have a good
conversation travel and just have a good
time that's my priority so it depends on
the person
wow that was beautiful this is why men
need to make money because Girls Just
Want to Have Fun Fun costs money men
need to make money because men want
women and women want fun but they're
making cost money and guys need to make
money because men want women and women
want fun and fun cost money and that's
just how it goes we're gonna do a
whiteboard episode on that right yeah
Girls Just Want to Have Fun
um you were saying what were you saying
about the the oh we were talking about
how delusional you are continue you're
saying that the guy that makes 10 20
million he could do whatever he wants
can he do any wrong to cheat on you
anything he's the last to be accountable
to me he's giving you an allowance and
you're driving a G wagon why is he still
accountable and and he's getting this
picture and I'm raising his children so
he's getting that [ __ ] so what do you
have like a magical [ __ ] that like has
leprechauns I honestly do you should hit
up my exit
this is what I say when I say women want
to be sold to dream
see it on you oh come on at least she
gets it she she knows what Rich problems
come with I think ideally no one wants
anyone it's not a unicorn I think a lot
of women would put up with it but this
is like the cognitive dissonance that I
think men have a problem with right so
here you are you got freaking Miss USA
over here miss Montana I mean I think
you should have won but I think it was
stolen from you however so on one hand
you want a guy that you can have fun
with that treats you right but you also
want a guy that makes 10 million dollars
a year ideally and you're acknowledging
the fact that if you're making 10
million bucks yeah I get it you're gonna
have you know More Money More Problems
but maybe that guy would treat you
better but he doesn't make enough money
does it just come down to Lifestyle that
like are women I guess Pro my question
to you is are are women realistic with
the lifestyle that they really want
versus what is the ideal lifestyle that
they actually probably need what are
your thoughts are they realistic with
the lifestyle yeah like these women are
obsessed with not this woman but women
are obsessed with the lifestyle I've
heard talk about this before what are
your thoughts on that well yeah I don't
I mean Women Marry a lifestyle I mean
because I mean who's the first one gone
when he loses his job her that's like
one of the number one indicators that
you're going to get divorced is if he
loses his job so that's why they say
like women can't love in the same way
that like men can love because once you
lose what you have like a lot of times
women leave
this is such a true this is such a good
point out there but why men fall in love
like ideally like ideologically like
romantically because there's no strings
attached I don't care baby like I don't
care what you do I don't care what you
make I don't care where your career is I
love you whereas women are like I love
you but I also love your Mansion your
house your cars even if you have kids or
whatever and I think ideal lifestyle and
I think the older a woman gets the
harder it is for her to genuinely love
like there are some girls that are ride
or dies right there are but they're but
I just have noticed they tend to be that
way if they met their man young and like
the more trauma like a girl's gone
through I just think it's harder for her
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible